it was a civil rights movement
denmark visa's insurrection was 1822.
it was a civil rights movement the
niagara
movement that led to the creation of the
naacp more than 100 years ago was the
civil rights movement
john lewis and i met
in october 1960 at
a civil rights movement
for as long as there are people
held in suppression
there will always be a movement
for civil rights however
in any movement
there will be a few sometimes only one
that rises head and shoulders
above all others and so it was
with my good friend john
robert lewis
when we met the weekend of october 13 14
15
1960 on the campus of mohawk's college
there was a little bit of an
insurrection taking place we who were
college students
felt that we knew how best to do things
we were not listening to martin luther
king jr and a few others
and so we asked
king to meet with us and he did
we went into the meeting around ten
o'clock in the evening
we did not walk out of that room until
four o'clock
the next morning i came
out of that room haven't had
a soul to paul
transformation i have never been the
same
since but
listen to king's plea for non-violence
i decided along with most others to
accept
non-violence as a tactic
but not john lewis he
internalized it it became
his way of life
and after going through a few issues of
the 60s
you know john got elected president of
snick in 1963 and was
1966
but john then joined the effort the
voter education project
where he directed that was sponsored by
the southern regional council
and as he served as director of the
voter education project
headquartered in atlanta i became the
chair of the voter education project
in charleston south carolina and we
continued that relationship
he got married to a librarian
i got married to a librarian
though i did so before he did
and they became fast friends
lillian and emily became fast friends
i will never ever
get john robert lewis
out of my system because he
succeeded where i failed
it was a tactic for me
it was a way of life for john lewis and
our year back
five legislative days in which to revise
and extend their remarks
and include extraneous material on the
subject of the special order
i now yield to thank you
i now yield to representative eleanor
norton holmes
from the district of columbia the
straight
estate of the district of columbia
i want to thank the gentlewoman from
california
karen bass for leading this special
order to our
good colleague and friend john lewis
uh john and i were elected
to the house of representatives about
the same time actually was elected a
couple years before i was
but we were colleagues before either of
us
could have hoped to become members of
congress we were
kids together in the student on violin
coordinating committee
the youth arm of the southern civil
rights movement
the difference between john and me is i
was in law school
so i went in the summer and john was a
full-time
member who left school in order
uh to join snick
and stick came out of count lunch
counters
ella baker called us all together
because it was clear that the civil
rights movement
was developing a youth arm and
elabor the great elder of the civil
rights movement decided all of us
should become we really should become an
organization
uh john was not the first head of snake
marion barry was
uh because he was a lot more political
than john
and he will be he's remembered today
more for his politics than for his civil
rights
uh acumen
when john was elected chair of snick
there was nothing political about it
his qualification was not that he was
the strongest or the most articulate or
whatever you want to call it
his strongest qualification was that he
was the bravest
pure and simple it was it is almost
impossible to describe
the risks john took uh in the more than
40 times he was arrested because today
we're so
used to civil disobedience people right
now are
lying down on pennsylvania avenue
on the george after the george floyd
killing so
we're we're used to that so i really
want to call to your attention what it
meant
when john led young people to be
arrested
you everybody has seen the
film of his being knocked down
as he marched in the front of the line
he had a concussion as a result of that
um he um
never knew uh as he led these marchers
whether he would come out alive let me
tell you
about these marches when snickwoods
would
kneel down and assume
other non-violent postures
on the other side we're not counter
demonstrations
demonstrators on the other side
were not people other people
who were confronting us non-violently
on the other side were the police
leading white mobs i must tell you they
were befuddled though by the tactics
of snick and the civil rights movement
because when you kneel down
non-violent they didn't quite know what
to do with you or about you
john of course will always be remembered
as a member of the house of
representatives
but as i close i must say it will be
difficult even for john
to have done more in the house than he
did
in the civil rights movement to do more
in congress than he did for his country
i thank the gentlewoman for yielding his
legacy to our country
is that he devoted his life to fighting
for justice
fighting for justice and being a moral
compass to our nation
i'd like to yield to representative
bobby scott from the great state of
virginia
thank you and i thank the gentlelady for
yielding mr speaker i rise today for a
solemn occasion
tonight we honor our friend brother
colleague
the conscience of the congress a true
american icon
congressman john lewis words cannot
convey the loss to this body as well as
to the nation
but very few can can claim to have
altered the course of american history
the way that john did
he was a guiding light to all of us and
was a leader trying to make america a
more perfect union
his steadfast moral leadership will be
deeply missed
particularly at this complex time in our
in our history
those of us here today are standing on
his shoulders
his historic life and legacy will
undoubtedly live on but we must be sure
to continue his life's work particularly
when it comes to voting rights
and restoring the voting rights act we
must make some good trouble
to honor his enormous legacy thank you
mr speaker i yield back
congressman john lewis spent his life
fighting racism and injustice
wherever he confronted it from boycotts
sit-ins and other protests in the
streets
to championing bold progressive policies
in congress
including the voting rights act i now
yield one minute to the representative
sheila jackson lee from texas
yes
we need to tell them who's next
let me come back to you uh
representative lee i'd like to
yield one minute to representative danny
davis from the state of illinois
so one minute
everyone has one minute i want to thank
the general lady
you know to every man there is a way a
ways
and a way the high souls take the
highway
and the low souls take the low while all
the rest
on the mr flats drift to and fro
but to every man there is a way of ways
and away and each man decided
which way his soul shall go
john lewis always took the high road
always giving of himself in such a way
that you knew that he was gracious and
kind john had faith
like john i grew up in rural america
went to a one-room school never had a
new school
book but john had the faith
of a mustard seed and said if
you want to move a mountain just say to
the mountain
be moved and if it wouldn't
then you get you some dynamite
nitroglycerin
tnt and blow that sucker down
that was john lewis may he rest in peace
now that he's no longer with us we have
to live up to his legacy and protect the
right to vote
for all americans as we continue to face
challenges due to the coronavirus
and issues of systemic racism we must
protect our democracy and elections
even in the midst of it adversity i now
yield to representative sheila jackson
lee from texas
one minute all speakers have one minute
we're all heartbroken
we all are speechless we all are
committed to john robert
lewis's beloved community each of us
have been touched
without ceasing for the spirit he led us
in acknowledging even in anger that
there was a beloved community
he loved his wife and his family and his
extended brothers and sisters
all the way from alabama to georgia
and i'm reminded of his ability to love
dr martin luther king it is the
testament of a man
that is able to extend love and not to
show
envy but to learn
and to seek knowledge john did that
which allowed him to carry that all the
way
to the fights of today john robert lewis
dr king said are you the boy from troy
he loved to tell that story he loved to
tell that he preached to the chickens
but his voices were heard by kings and
queens
john robert lewis a saint walking on
earth
i'm reminded of our days in front of the
south african
embassy arrested against uh genocide
or fighting against the children in
cages john never stopped his fight
and so i come today to honor him in this
brief moment that we have
to be able to say isn't it good that a
saintly man walked on this earth and
reminded us
of the beloved community i am
very glad to say that i knew and the
world knows
john robert lewis the boy
from troy with that i yield back
yes i now yield one minute to
representative gregory meeks from new
york
john robert lewis was short in height
yet he was a giant john robert lewis was
a humbled man
but fierce for justice
john robert lewis talked softly
but roared like a lion when it was time
to fight for freedom justice and
equality
for the all for all humankind
he said there was one race the human
race
he is an individual that compelled a
nation
to change to make it better his voice
will echo in this chamber
forever it was my
honor and pleasure for 22 years
to serve with the honorable
john robert lewis may he rest in peace
and rise in power
i yield one minute to representative
david scott
from georgia
thank you very much john lewis's
mother and his grandmother
named him john
after john the apostle
the disciple the scripture says
whom jesus loved john the beloved
and john himself lewis
dedicated his life to building the
beloved
community and one more thing
john lewis being named after john
jesus's apostle it must be noted
that the apostle john
was the youngest of the disciples
john lewis was the youngest
of our civil rights leaders
who spoke at the momentous
march on washington god bless
john lewis and we thank god
for sending him our way
i yield i yield one minute to
al green representative al green from
texas
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
i rise to say thank you to a friend
and a great warrior i thank you dear
brother for
being the sermon you preached
you walked your talk
it is said that a great person will
always rise to the occasion
but has also said that the greater
person makes the occasion
he was an occasion maker and he rose to
the occasion on the edmund pettus bridge
and for this many of us who are here
tonight
are here because he
marched into brutality
so tonight i thank you dear brother
for being able to withstand what many of
us
could not and would not
i rise to just say thank you and to let
you know that we will never forget
you and we will always
make it perspicuously clear that we are
here
because you were there i yield back
mr speaker i yield one minute to
representative yvette clark from new
york
mr speaker today i rise
to honor a great man the representative
john lewis
this past friday july 17th our country
lost one of our
its greatest heroes a true patriot who
literally put his life on the line
in the pursuit of justice and fairness
in our society
the honorable john lewis was a
penultimate hero
who embodied the struggle for human
rights and dignity
he was a fierce civil rights warrior who
refused to abide with the jim
crow laws of the south he embodied what
it means to be a public servant putting
his life on the line
and the people above his own
self-interest i'm so honored and
privileged to have served with john
robert lewis john robert lewis who
was a dancer a man who loved to have fun
but was convicted for the right to vote
convicted
as an activist for civil rights and
civil liberties
and i will forever hold dear the moment
that we
landed in ghana together invited by the
president of ghana
for the right to return and to see the
wonderment in his eyes
of visiting a space where it all began
for all of us 401 years ago
may he rest in peace and rise in power
the honorable john lewis will never be
forgotten
we all hold on to his legacy to honor mr
lewis the first thing we need to do is
to pass legislation restoring the voting
rights act
and get it signed we know the
credibility of our elections has already
shown
early signs of concern during several
state primaries
and voter suppression cases coupled with
the fact that people are going to have
to vote in dangerous conditions
cannot be ignored i know that if mr
lewis was still with us
he would be leading that fight mr
speaker i yield
one minute to representative hank
johnson from georgia
i thank the speaker and i think the
general lady from california
mr speaker much has been said about
my friend teacher and mentor
john lewis he was a
family man married to lillian for 44
years
and to that union bore a son
john miles who is with us today
along with john lewis's brothers and
sisters he was
number three of ten so he's got a large
extended family
and that family entrusted
john to the world and for 33 years he
was our colleague
for 14 years he was mine i just want to
say to the family
that we here in congress feel your pain
we appreciate your sacrifice in allowing
john to do what he did for the world and
for congress
i want you to know that we stand with
you
we feel your pain and we will never
forget
your dear brother uncle
cousin whoever he was to you we will
never forget him we know that he loved
you
he would depart this place to go to the
family reunion
during the summer down in alabama where
the family still
owned hundreds of acres of land that
they farmed
even when his two sharecropping parents
uh gave birth to john and so he was a
family man
thank you family for entrusting him to
us
and with that i yield back
being managed by congressman sanford
bishop of georgia mr bishop
thank you mr speaker we're here today to
honor
congressman john robert lewis our hero
our colleague our brother our friend
having known john for 52 years i can
tell you honestly that even in his
humanity
he lived his life in the image
of jesus john was a voice for the
voiceless
african-americans for women for lgbtq
people for the least and the left out
for anyone
mistreated by society his unwavering
sense of right and wrong was a north
star for this nation which is why
we called him the conscience of the
congress people as good as
john don't come our way very often
despite all the accolades and
recognition
he received john remained humbled
unfailingly canned
and always show the capacity of people
to be better despite their past
transgressions
where would america be today if it were
not for john lewis
without his activism without his courage
without his perseverance
for voting rights i doubt if i'd be here
today
thank you john for your lifetime of
advocacy for sacrifice for friendship
and counsel
and thank you god for the life of john
robert lewis at this time
i am delighted to yield to the gentleman
from
indiana mr andre carson
thank you it's recognized for one
for one minute thank you chair and thank
you mr speaker
john lewis was certainly a leader
amongst men he was a mentor he was a
friend
my heart goes out to his family our
hearts go out to his family i can
remember mr speaker
during the health care vote i was coming
out of cannon i ran into john
and he asked how many votes do we have
left or how much time do we have left i
said i think we'll make it we
cross the street along with his chief
michael and there were thousands of
people yelling kill the bill
kill the bill kill the bill
and that wasn't it they were yelling
expletives racial expletives
at the three of us and john looked at me
and said brother andre this reminds me
of a darker time brother
john became a mentor we'd call him up
and he'd speak to the muslim community
we'd call him up and he'd speak to the
folks in indiana who were there when it
was announced that
dr king had passed because he was in
indianapolis at the time
he was a true servant mr speaker
jesus was mentioned john was like jesus
i'm reminded of
a scripture when jesus was having a
conversation with his disciples about
this notion of leadership
and jesus looked at his disciples and
said he who wishes to be
chief amongst you shall first be your
servant john was a servant
he wasn't the kind of leader that looked
at the protesters today and said ah
what you're going through is nothing
compared to what we went through
he stood in solidarity with those young
folks
and embraced those young folks like a
real leader
and john as an example to all of us
where true public servants
should be we love you john god bless
mr bishop you're recognized
we make our living by what we get
we make a life by what we give
john lewis certainly made a life i'm
pleased
to yield to the gentlelady from
california
ms maxine waters
well i'm happy to yield to the
gentlelady from alabama
mr terry sewell general lady from
selma alabama miss terry sewell
is recognized for one minute
mr speaker i rise today to honor the
life
and outstanding legacy of our colleague
friend mentor and my hero
congressman john robert lewis
growing up as a little girl in selma
alabama john's incredible legacy
was a hero's tale as familiar to me as
any bible story or family lore
as a little girl singing in the choir
the children's choir at brown chapel ame
church
my home church the church where john
and so many wonderful foot soldiers
would come time and time again
to honor the legacy of the bloody sunday
march
but to know john was to know a man
without ego who despite his
well-deserved accolades
and successes loved every person he met
he looked them in the eye can't you hear
him my brother
my sister he would say john loved this
country more than any person that i met
and it was his deep seated patriotism
that will live
on his legacy indeed was the voting
rights act
and we in this body can do something
about that
yes we can name things for john but the
biggest name
the biggest thing that we can do is
rename hr4
never give in keep your eyes
on the prize keep the faith
generator yields back mr bishop
george washington carver once said how
far you go in life depends on
your being tender with the young
compassionate with aged
sympathetic with the striving and
tolerant of the weak and strong
because someday in your life you will
have been
all of these that
was our friend john lewis i'm delighted
to yield to
the gentlelady from ohio
joyce beatty generator from ohio
congresswoman joyce beatty is recognized
for one minute
thank you mr speaker america has lost a
national treasure
one of the world's greatest fighters and
defenders of freedom
and justice congressman lewis's
words and work and legacy will live
forever
i am so fortunate to have traveled to
africa with him
and to marched in my hometown with them
you see mr speaker when mr lewis spoke
you heard the voice of history a voice
that helped stir the conscious
of america and at a time of ugliness
and struggle but also at a time
in an era of hope and accomplishment
so my colleagues there is no greater
time for us to stand
up against injustices that we are facing
no greater time for us to fight
for justice and fairness at the ballot
box
so my colleagues let us make some noise
let us get in trouble good trouble
god bless you rest in peace
rest in power my friend
good trouble
chair recognizes mr bishop
i am pleased to yield to the gentlelady
from ohio
miss robin kelly general later from
illinois miss kelly is recognized
generated from correct illinois
thank you mr speaker i want to share my
letter to congressman john
robert lewis dear john
i hope you knew how incredibly honored i
was to call you colleague and to serve
with you
it was such a great privilege to watch
you in action
and listen to your stories when we
planned to sit in being a part of the
fab
five made me so proud it took a while to
get the bill
out of the house but we finally did it
i promise you when i encounter a
situation that is just not right
i will stand up speak out and get in the
way
i plan to carry a piece of you with me
forever
i know i will be a better person for it
i hope you ct vivian martin
rosa edgar and robert kennedy and others
are having a fabulous reunion rest in
power my friend
until we meet again love robin
mr bishop mr speaker how much time
remains
23. your advice that you have 22 minutes
remaining
thank you at this time i'm delighted to
yield one minute to the dental lady from
michigan
representative brenda lawrence
congresswoman
lawrence is recognized thank you just
this year i remember john
urging americans to get into good
trouble necessary trouble
and to help redeem the soul of america
as we combat some of the most hateful
messages and priorities driven
by this current administration today i
stand here
john i promise that i will continue to
carry out your legacy
to get into good trouble and to ensure
that the fight for equality and justice
lives on
and challenge my colleagues on both
sides of the aisle
to do the same to do the same and pass
the voting rights act
john will rest in peace rest in power
you have been a good and faithful
servant and i yield back
generally is back mr bishop at this time
i'm delighted to yield
to the gentleman from pennsylvania
representative dwight evans the
gentleman from pennsylvania mr dwight
evans is recognized
mr speaker i rise
to honor truly a great american
and a real life hero i was fortunate
enough to have
him as a colleague for four years
congressman john lewis has been an
inspiration to me
at a very young age i remember the first
time i saw him
was on the evening news
he was walking across the petted bridge
i felt very strongly about him and what
he was doing
i was 10 years old
and i found him to be inspiring
he was purposeful he was driven to make
a difference
he was driven to make some good trouble
now we must carry on
with the work of civil rights
and equal opportunity rest empower
congressman lewis mr bishop
at this time i'm delighted to yield to
the general lady from florida
representative val dimmings general lady
from florida congresswoman val dimmings
is recognized
mr speaker on june 12th of 2016
a long gunman walked into the pulse
nightclub in orlando florida and opened
fire
with a semi-automatic rifle that night
the shooter killed 49 people
and injured 53 others at the time
it was the largest mass shooting in
american history
the pulse nightclub is in my district
but i was not in congress
at the time but when i saw the members
of
congress taken to the floor and holding
a sit-in
i was not surprised that the person
leading the way
was representative john lewis to him
the victims were a part of the big
family
john lewis often spoke about thank you
john
for never discriminating thank you john
for never leaving people
behind galatians 5 defines the fruit of
the spirit as
love peace long-suffering
kindness goodness faithfulness
gentleness and self-control john lewis
was
all of that to the house to the nation
and to the world and i am grateful for
his friendship
and his counsel and grateful for a life
well-lived thank you mr speaker i yield
back
general lady yields back mr bishop at
this time i'm delighted to
yield to the gentlelady from georgia uh
representative
lucy macbeth the general lady from the
state of georgia
congresswoman lucy macbeth is recognized
thank you so much thank you so much mr
speaker
tonight we stand in this great chamber
and mourn our friend
a civil rights icon and the conscience
of congress
john lewis towered over his era
and his losses deeply felt across this
country and across the globe
from marching for freedom in montgomery
to being beaten and bloodied on a bridge
in selma
john's life showed us all the
fundamental need
for good necessary trouble
as john would often say we have a moral
obligation a mission and a mandate
to do what we can to make our country in
a world a
better place and to help usher in
a loving community where no one
is left out or left behind
his words and his life ring
through eternity we will honor
john's legacy with an unshakable
determination
to fight for what is right and what
is just he served the nation
in love rest in peace
my friend we love you
i love you thank you and i yield back
the balance of my time
general lady yields back very requests
the amount of time remaining
the gentleman has 15 minutes remaining
at this time i'm delighted to yield to
uh the gentleman from maryland mr kwaisi
the gentleman from maryland mr kwazii
impumi is recognized
thank you mr speaker as we've been
hearing and will continue to hear the
passing of
john lewis represents a loss for america
of one of her greatest heroes
and for many of us a dear and old friend
john and i were sworn in together in
this chamber 33
years ago as classmates in the 100th
congress
there were only four african americans
elected to congress that year
he myself floyd flake of new york and
mike espy of
mississippi and we huddled with john
here on the floor and he made all of us
hug
each other and he said we got here in
different ways but we are one band
of brothers now the passion and the
equality
that he carried with him throughout his
life as we know never
waned and his untiring quest
for justice never faltered
with a big heart for compassion john
like his mentor dr
martin luther king jr was
unawed by opinion unseduced
by flattery and undismayed by
disaster birthed in an era of jim crow
and vile and vicious segregation he
defied the limitedness
of others expectations
john knew that politics changed people
so he set out early to change politics
everything about him pointed to the fact
that he was emblematic of that great
band of freedom fighters
who realized that freedom wasn't free
and so in this era where everyone seems
to be searching
for the next big thing or the next great
thing
isn't it odd mr speaker that the
greatness of john lewis
was with us all along we needed only to
look as far
as the latest movement for social change
to find it we are sad today
but heaven is rejoicing and john has
claimed his final reward
i yield back the balance of my time
thank you sir the gentleman years back
it has been said that service is the
rent we pay
for the space we occupy on this earth
john lewis paid his rent and he paid it
well
at this time i'm delighted to yield to
the gentleman from texas
representative will hurd the gentleman
from the 23rd district of texas
congressman will hurt is recognized a
freedom rider
unshaken by threats and violence
a leader in the struggle for voting
rights who kept fighting
even after a broken skull a courageous
american
undeterred by more than 40 arrests after
standing up for what's right
john lewis spent his life fighting
injustice and racism
if it weren't for the bravery of john
and men and women like him
many of us wouldn't be in this chamber
today and as a black man i'm not sure
i would have had the same rights as my
fellow countrymen john shaped this
country
in immeasurable ways he never set by
when he saw injustice he never stopped
fighting
and at a time when america is so divided
we should look at john's courage for
inspiration we should look at john's
bravery for imitation
and we should look at john's words and
follow them
i lost a mentor john's family lost a
father
son brother and husband our country lost
an american hero rest in peace my
brother
the gentleman yields back mr bishop i'm
delighted to yield at this time to the
gentlelady from california
representative barbara lee general lady
from california congresswoman barbara
lee
is now recognized thank you mr speaker
what a void what a void we feel tonight
i rise to honor the life and legacy of a
great warrior for peace and justice a
kind and gentle human being the
conscience of the congress
congressman john lewis now as
a giant of and as our whip indicated
a civil rights movement john's
leadership
and his courage continued as an
extraordinary
congressional leader every year i joined
john on his annual pilgrimage to selma
montgomery and birmingham alama
i brought young people from the martin
luther king freedom center
in my district and my grandchildren each
year
to learn about and give thanks to the
foot soldiers of the civil rights
movement
john always he always took time
to meet with these young people even
this year
with his failing health he pulled them
aside he met with them he always wanted
and he did
inspire them to take that baton and to
run
the next lap of the race for justice and
equality
and yes like with so many he blessed my
community
by coming to my district to continue
these efforts with my young people
last year speaker pelosi and chairwoman
bass led a delegation
to ghana west africa to observe the
400th anniversary
of the first enslaved africans brought
to america
john said he said that ghana was one of
the most
moving trips of his life and he said and
i quote
to see and behold the inhumanity
during another period of our history he
said it tells
each and every one of us never to let
this evil happen
again now john was welcomed in ghana
as royalty which he was
and he was honored as a son of africa
who had come home
john and i would compare notes on tough
votes such as
on matters of war and peace and defense
spending
i will miss his wise counsel and
admonition
and really admonition to do the right
thing
as he told all of us to keep our eyes on
the prize
now members know how we get agitated
when our colleagues
poach our staff members well john
poached
a brilliant and wonderful young woman
from my office jamila thompson
and when he told me about it believe it
or not
for the first time i was thrilled
i was thrilled that one of my staff
members had been poached by john lewis
what an
honor john's presence in the people's
house will be deeply missed
but one of the greatest tributes to
congressman john lewis would be to
restore the voting rights act
i would not be standing here as the
100th black member of congress had it
not been for the honorable john
robert lewis my deepest condolences and
love and gratitude to john's family
michael collins jamila thompson his
entire phenomenal staff and his
constituents
and to all those whose lives he touched
let us continue to build the beloved
community that he so eloquently spoke of
in closing i am reminded of a scripture
second timothy chapter four verse six
verse seven excuse me i have fought the
good fight
i have finished the race i have kept the
faith
as john lewis's soul returns to his
creator
may he rest in peace may he rest in
power
generally yields back how much time is
remaining
gentlemen has seven minutes remaining
as we come to the close of this first
hour of tribute to
our friend and our colleague and our
hero
john robert lewis
i leave you with the words of douglas
malloch who wrote a tree
that never had to fight for sun and sky
and air and light that stood out in the
open plain and always
got its share of rain never became a
forest king
but lived and died a scrubby thing
a man who never had to toil by hand
or mind in life's turmoil who never had
to earn his share
of sun and sky and light and air
never became a manly man but
lived and died as he began
good timber doesn't grow in ease
the stronger wind the stronger trees
the farther sky the greater length the
rougher storms
the greater strength by wind arraigned
by
sutter snow in trees
or man good timbers grow
john robert lewis
was indeed good timber
god bless his soul may he rest
in peace and in power
the gentleman yields back his time
under the speaker's announced policy of
january 3rd 2019
the gentlewoman from wyoming miss cheney
is now recognized for 60 minutes as a
designee of the minority
leader thank you very much mr speaker
and mr speaker it's my honor this
evening
to oversee the time to manage the time
that
we have on the republican side to
celebrate and remember
the life of our tremendous colleague mr
john lewis
mr speaker i was very moved having the
opportunity to watch my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle discuss and describe the impact
that congressman lewis had
on their lives on all of our lives
and and on this chamber and i'm struck
by the fact that that as we gather
tonight
in this chamber we rise not as
representatives of two different
political parties
uh but we rise as representatives
elected representatives of this great
nation
and a nation that's mourning the loss of
a great american
and an honored colleague as a man john
lewis who dedicated his life
to service and to the fight for justice
and freedom
john lewis taught us quote nothing can
stop the power of a committed
and determined people to make a
difference in our society
why because human beings are the most
dynamic
link to the divine on this planet
john lewis understood that one man or
woman can make a difference
indeed that it is only the determined
and principled action
of committed men and women that brings
change
he knew the blessings of this nation and
he knew what it took to secure
those blessings for all americans he
knew
that the fight was unfinished mr speaker
the day that i was sworn into this body
for the first time
i was standing just outside these doors
in the speakers lobby
i had just arrived with my dad who
joined me on the floor that day
by chance as we were coming in we met
john lewis standing in the lobby and the
three of us
had the chance before the ceremony to
spend some time together
the two of them don't didn't agree on
much
but they did agree on certain critical
things
they agreed on the exceptional nature of
this country
on the magnificence of this the people's
house
and on the incalculable blessings of
freedom
and i am blessed by the memory of that
day and i am blessed that at that moment
when i was about to be sworn into this
house
i was able to spend time with those two
men
writing of his experiences fighting for
civil rights john lewis said this
quote freedom is not a state it is an
act
it is not some enchanted garden perched
high
on a distant plateau where we can
finally sit down and rest
freedom is the continuous action we all
must take
and each generation must do its part to
create an even more fair
and more just society great men
and women like john lewis in every
generation have known this
that we all have an obligation to defend
our freedom
to fight for it to do our part to be
worthy of the sacrifices of those who
have gone before
one of the greatest gifts we can give to
young people today
is to teach them that lesson to teach
them our history convey to them the duty
the obligation and the incredible
blessing of being an american
and of working to make sure that we pass
this nation to our children
and our grandchildren more perfect than
it is today
our colleague congressman john lewis
dedicated his life to that ideal
his memory will be a blessing and an
example to us all
our colleagues his colleagues here in
the house
to his family to his constituents and to
his fellow americans
god bless john lewis and god bless the
united states of america
thank you very much mr speaker and with
that
i will yield to the gentleman from north
carolina mr walker
the gentleman from north carolina mr
mark walker is recognized
thank you madam chair we're honored to
participate in this special order
and we will look forward to hearing from
our speakers
in honoring the great john lewis and
tonight we would like to begin
with mr steny hoyer as he
you'll time to him all right we will we
will skip over that right quick and then
uh okay well then we'll start with some
opening comments and then we'll wait
when it shows up there gentleman's
record thank you mr speaker
over this past weekend america not only
lost a civil rights icon
but also a loving father a loving
husband
a caring friend to this entire house
body
congressman john lewis mr lewis's
courage and strength in the face of
oppression is unmatched
his contributions to america's soul is
paramount to the progress that we have
made
in our histories his experience on
bloody sunday left him battered
covered in blood and on the side of the
road in selma alabama
yet he carried on with his unifying
message for america
many years ago john lewis crossed the
monumental edmund pettus bridge
fighting for freedom and a path towards
achieving what our founding fathers had
pledged
but fell short to uphold i was extremely
honored to have the opportunity 54 years
later to walk across this very bridge in
selma
and we all honor the brave steps he led
rallying an entire nation
the fact that i was asked to give the
close remarks at dexter avenue king
memorial baptist church in montgomery is
something
frankly that i'll always treasure john
lewis protest inspired our nation
to not only do better but to reflect on
all of our actions
through his grace and humility he made
monumental progress
he liked to refer these acts as good
trouble
when we don't share many of the same
political opinions there was never a
doubt in my mind
the congressman john lewis lived his
entire life fighting for our country
and the american people he gave us all
hope
hope that we could get over this
partisan divide hope that we could get
over the divisions
of the past to paint a brighter future
may we never lose his spirit and forever
honor his legacy
by never letting the forces of division
hatred and evil
tear down those bridges that so many of
us have sacrificed
to divide and with that i yield to
our whip congressman steve scalise the
gentleman from louisiana the republican
whip is recognized
thank you mr speaker i thank my friend
and colleague
from north carolina for yielding and
joined with
my colleagues both republican and
democrat
who mourn the loss of john lewis you
know we
we have so many honors to to be able to
serve in a job like this where we get to
represent
the people's nation especially here in
the people's house where
you truly do bring in all of the
different elements of what makes america
great
into one body with people who represent
every different
type of background and every different
kind
of community the kinds of
people that we get to serve with and
there are giants
among the people that we have the honor
of serving with
john lewis was at the top of that list
and you knew it when you served with him
i remember telling colleagues years ago
that while we have our differences
it's really important to go get to know
especially some of the legends
the giants that we serve within this
body i remember talking about two
members in particular
it was john lewis and sam johnson
one democrat one republican two people
who were just giants unfortunately
we've now lost both of them in the last
year
our institution is better because john
lewis
was a part of this great body but
it's what john fought for his whole life
when i know my colleague from north
carolina as well as my colleagues
in the congressional black caucus talked
about earlier his
his mantra of good trouble
what john experienced in his life
there are so many people who have
freedoms today they would never have
if john hadn't gone through that i
had an honor like so many of my
colleagues to go with john he invited
members from both parties to go to selma
to be a part
of reliving that history which was the
dark side of our history
bloody sunday but one that john used as
a teachable moment
to bring people from all parts of this
country
to walk across that edmund pettus bridge
and i got to walk arm
and arm with john it was one of the
great honors i've had as a member of
congress to be able to do that
and the whole time you're walking with
him this
this could be a moment that john wants
to wants to just leave in his past
because he was so brutally beaten but he
wanted to share
the experiences and as we were walking
we would round the corner
and he would point to different
buildings so that we
that's where we gathered that's where
some of the people who were trying to
stop us would be
he helped organize the student
nonviolent committee snik and
nssncc and he started at a young age
in the civil rights movement at a time
when
it was not only difficult but it was
possibly life-threatening and for many
they did lose their life in that battle
and john lost blood
he shed blood for the cause but he
never took it as a moment to get down he
never
took it as a moment to be bitter he
wanted to continue fighting to
make america
spirit he was one of those very few
people
in a body like this where when he stood
at the podium to speak
no matter what side you were on on that
issue you
stopped you sat down and you listened
because you knew you were listening to
somebody
who was larger than life john's in a
better place
right now but america is a better place
because john was here
god bless john lewis and his family and
i yield back
to my friend from north carolina's back
mr walker thank you man i'd like to
recognize
doris matsui from california generator
from california mr
smithson is recognized thank you mr
speaker i rise today to speak
in honor of beloved colleague and
wonderful friend john lewis
i first met john when my late husband
bob met so he was a member of congress
bob loved john he loved him for his
humanity his conviction
and the fact that he was a total human
being i had heard so much about john
because he was a historic figure
but i saw another side of him too when
bob brought him to sacramento
and he met many people and i remember
his walking across a university campus
with the president of the university
when he ran across
bob and he and john a bunch of chickens
that the students were advocating for to
keep on campus
and the president was saying no we got
to get the chickens out
and the president says excuse me
uh mr lewis but we're gonna get rid of
those chickens and john said no way
you're gonna get rid of those chickens
i learned to preach by preaching to
chickens
and that is the part of john that i
really love too that humorous part
the parts you can laugh with but this
gentle giant
lived also every single day to overcome
injustice
eradicate racism and give hope to all
who walked
beside him and he is a total person
and at this moment in our history when
speaking truth to power is so vital
is more important than ever to follow
john's words
to stand up speak out and keep your eyes
on the prize
john taught us all that america is
greater than the sum of his parts
when you weave a rich colorful tapestry
the weaving itself makes us strong
his impact will be forever felt our
nation's conscience
and we're all better for it at this
difficult time
my prayers are with the lewis family and
all his friends
and he will be solely miss i love you
john yield back general lady yields back
the speaker i'd like to recognize only
first makes sense to
john lewis's colleagues the delegation
from georgia starting with their deputy
whip
uh congressman drew ferguson gentlemen
from georgia is recognized thank you mr
speaker and the gentleman from north
carolina thank you
for allowing me to do this i rise to
honor tonight to honor
the life and legacy of john lewis john
had dedicated
his life to equality and justice and the
nation we are so blessed to live in
is better because of his work and his
sacrifice
john was driven by his deep faith his
servant heart
and his love of his fellow human being
and while john was
always right to fight for legal changes
to make america better
he ultimately knew that how you treated
your fellow human being was a matter of
the heart
and john led by example he led by
showing love and grace to all people
he showed even though he showed love and
grace even to those people
that disagreed with him or showed him
contempt
john was always offer always willing to
offer
forgiveness to those who had done him
wrong
knowing that forgiveness was fundamental
to building a relationship built on
trust and love
two of my most vivid memories and
treasured experiences here in my time in
congress involved john
one was a dinner at his house he invited
the georgia delegation over
and he retold the story of his life
and experiences in the civil rights
movement what a cherished memory
and experience the second was the night
that we ordered that we honored another
georgia giant here
former house member and former u.s
senator johnny isakson
i remember the night that johnny isakson
and john lewis
met in the center and embraced
in true love friendship and respect
it's truly an amazing moment john
was an amazing man and i believe that
the only thing john lewis ever hated
was hate itself rest in peace our dear
friend
mr speaker i'd like to recognize the
gentlelady from
new york nidaloy general lady from new
york
miss nina loy is recognized mr speaker
i rise to honor the memory
of congressman john lewis
an american hero a dear friend
he taught us what patriotism is
that to love our country is to
acknowledge and work to repair
its imperfections congressman lewis
endured
angry mobs death threats
so much violence with endurance
persistence
and even warmth and optimism surely we
can honor his
remarkable life by coming together to
reauthorize the voting rights act
to ensure our laws reflect that black
lives matter
advocating for the nation's marginalized
throughout his life
acting as the conscience of congress
during his 34 years of service
he inspired generations of americans to
get
in good trouble i remember sitting on
the floor with john
rather than sitting on the chair we were
proving our point and all
sitting on the floor he has taught us so
much
with his sweet sweet manner but the
strength of his conviction
we must honor congressman lewis's legacy
by striving to achieve the equitable
and just society for all that he fought
so hard to attain
in the words of john himself if not us
then who if not now then when
dear sweet kind john we will miss you
we love you may you rest in peace
mr speaker like to recognize the
gentleman from georgia representative
austin scott
the gentleman from georgia mr scott is
recognized thank you mr speaker and i'd
like to thank the gentleman from north
carolina for a few minutes to
speak about my friend and colleague
congressman john lewis
and the man that i loved and i will miss
dearly him saying
i love you too brother there's no
telling how many times
john lewis told the people of this house
i love you too brother
and he looked at everybody no matter who
you were
as a brother and i selfishly thought
about how much i was going to miss him
and uh seeing him and michael collins on
a delta ready to fly up here and i
always got a kick out of the fact that
people from my district would sit down
next to me and say did you see john
lewis on the plane
and by the way what do you do and
and that was just the way people love
john lewis
there's not a person walking
in this country today that didn't
benefit from john lewis and what he did
for mankind and i would venture to say
that the majority of the people in the
world
benefited from his love and what he did
so i thought about a few passages we've
talked about him preaching to the
chickens and maybe where the chickens
that he was preaching to his whole life
but i remembered
the beatitudes blessed are the
peacemakers for they shall be called the
children of god
if there was ever a peacemaker that i
met it was john lewis
and if you follow from there blessed are
they which are persecuted for
righteousness
sake for theirs is the kingdom of heaven
a little further into the book of
matthew let your light shine
before men that they may see your good
works and glorify your father which is
in heaven
there is no doubt ladies and gentlemen
that john lewis was a special man he was
a special man of god
a special man of god and while his bones
his bones may rest his legacy will live
on forever
in this body and i for one look very
forward to the day that a statue
of john lewis rests in the halls of this
congress
representing not only the great state of
georgia and the people of the state of
georgia
but all of the men and women of the
united states
thank you representative scott we would
like to recognize the gentlelady from
california
susan davis generator from california
congresswoman susan davis
thank you thank you mr speaker mr
speaker with john
robert lewis's passing we lose
and deeply mourn a great friend and
mentor
and the world loses the most respected
good trouble maker of our time
john standing will only grow as his
legacy
endures mr speaker every time every year
since i've been in congress
i asked john to speak to entering high
school seniors from san diego who
visited our capitol as part of an
in-depth civics
and leadership program and for 20 years
with each new group of 45
very diverse students he gave his time
his energy and wisdom graciously
answering
their many spirited questions and they
too
will never forget him and how he changed
them
and here's just a brief example
alejandra cordova from
2001 said mr lewis taught her not to be
afraid
to rock the boat every once in a while
and david hickman from 2015 said
he truly showed us what it meant to be a
change-maker
to live through our actions and speak up
against injustice he taught our children
well
john you taught and changed me
and everyone you touched thank you
and thank you michael collins and all of
john's staff
who had the hardest task of all to say
to visitors
captured by john's words i'm sorry
but the congressman must depart now
mr speaker like to recognize a fellow
pastor and representative from georgia
representative jody heiss the gentleman
from georgia mr heist is recognized
i thank you mr speaker and thank my good
friend from north carolina
there's no question that all of us who
have served with
john lewis mourn the passing of this
towering figure who devoted his life to
fighting for freedom and equality
an interesting perspective of his life
is the son of
alabama sharecroppers john lewis
demonstrated
that in america a single individual
even one coming from the most humble
backgrounds
can have an enormous impact
in this country we all know that he rose
to be a powerful leader in the civil
rights movement
worked very closely with dr martin
luther king and so many other
great heroes who sacrificed their lives
to ensure that americans
of all races live in liberty in this
country
but he did so peacefully he once wrote
this and this has a great
uh powerful meaning he said release the
need to hate
to par harbor division and the
enticement of revenge
release all bitterness hold only
love only peace in your heart
knowing that the battle of good to
overcome evil
is already won john lewis knew that it
was necessary to fight the sins of this
country
but he understood also to fight those
in a non-violent way and i just had the
deepest respect for john lewis
and am honored to have considered him a
dear friend and i just want to thank all
my colleagues
this evening for joining in this time to
honor
such a great man and uh an
icon obviously particularly in the civil
rights
movement but my wife dede and i
continue to pray for the lewis family
and again i just say thank you to all my
colleagues for joining tonight
my yield back gentlemen yields back
like to recognize the gentleman from new
jersey representative donald payne
gentleman from new jersey congressman
donald payne is recognized
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
thank the gentleman from north carolina
for allowing me
uh several minutes to pay my respects to
um a great man and it's not remiss
that i see uh the speaker
pro temp very appropriate that you're in
the seat tonight sir
mr speaker i rise today
to honor john lewis
he was an american icon
civil rights legend and dear friend
and an inspiration to millions
yet these words truly fail to describe
the difference he made in our country
he always spoke of getting into good
trouble
and i know that's been echoed here on
numerous occasions
but it sums up what
mr lewis was all about his efforts
led to the civil rights act
his efforts led to the voting rights act
and this effort led to the congressional
black caucus
and even the election of president
barack obama but his
loss is more than his legacy
for me once again
i've lost one of my fathers
on the floor of congress he was a role
model
for what makes a great congressman
and i constantly watched as he moved
about
his business like the way he
always fought for the right thing
the way he could convey such power
and strength
through such a gentle demeanor
but when he had passion
and was committed there is no one else
on this floor you would rather have with
you
going into that fight
and the way he stood up to abuse to make
this country
a better place one of my greatest honors
was to be a part of the sit-in he led
on the house floor to fight
for gun control legislation
after the terrible terrible
dreadful florida issue
we got into some good trouble that day
he inspired us then and his words and
deeds will inspire new generations
whether they are civil rights pioneers
elected officials
or any american with a dream or cause
god bless you mr lewis
your life made our country and our world
a better place and with that i yield
back
gentlemen yields back mr walker mr
speaker may i get a time remaining
gentlemen has 32 minutes remaining thank
you mr speaker i'd like to recognize the
gentleman from georgia mr rick allen
gentlemen from georgia is recognized i
thank the gentleman from north carolina
for this privilege
mr speaker many americans learned about
the civil rights movement
in the news or read about it in history
books
john lewis lived it
one of my greatest memories here was to
have dinner
with congressman lewis at his home where
he shared with the entire georgia
delegation his experience
in leading the civil rights movement he
shared with me that dr martin
luther king jr prayed with them on those
buses before the demonstrations
and urge everyone to remain at peace to
ensure
lasting change i think we can all learn
from the example
congressman lewis set as a civil rights
icon
we must we must meet injustice
with humility and perseverance to do
what is right pride and fear
are the opposite of humility john lewis
and all those in this movement
demonstrated perfect love
while being persecuted perfect love
casts out all fear and only
comes from god in obedience to his word
and was perfectly demonstrated at the
cross
of jesus christ my wife robin and i pray
that
his family finds peace during this
difficult time
and this is a lesson for this body as we
honor those who
like uh john lewis who have come before
us
and fought for an america that is
stronger and is unified
by putting aside our differences to
serve the american people
in perfect love and i yield back
mr speaker like to recognize the
gentleman from memphis with his own
amazing civil rights history mr steve
cohen the gentleman from memphis
tennessee congressman steve coyne is now
recognized
thank you mr speaker and i appreciate
the time mr walker and i will
remember the last time i saw john lewis
was march the fifth his birthday
and you offered the prayer and that
meant a lot to me and it showed me the
respect that you had for him and that he
had for you
it was a beautiful moment there was not
a more perfect person
that's probably served in congress
certainly that i've known in my life
than john r lewis
he had every quality that you would
desire in a human being
and couldn't even imagine a person to
have them all together
he was a hero of the civil rights
movement and cared about
greatly the injustices that he had seen
as an african-american
and that's what launched him on the
civil rights struggles
but once he got moving it was people of
different issues of discrimination that
he championed
whether it was gay and lesbians whether
it was native americans
whether it was women or they're just
simple being
people being victims of gun violence
john lewis took up
the cause and he stood up for everybody
he did not know color he did not know
gender
he did not know any differences in
people he loved
all people it was such an honor to serve
with him
early in my career the american bar
association presented
their day award to john lewis richard
lugar and myself
the award was nothing compared to the
fact that i was with john lewis that day
it made me feel much greater than i
ever could become i had the great honor
to travel with him to south africa
for the 50th anniversary of robert f
kennedy's ripple of hope speech
in cape town and i saw and i sat across
from he and
bishop desmond tutu and i knew i was
seeing two
angels together two special souls
united
mr mr lewis loved two people in life
that were his heroes
one was dr martin luther king and
another was robert kennedy
and that purpose of that speech that
trip was to honor robert kennedy that
50th anniversary of that speech
in that speech robert kennedy said it is
from
numberless diverse acts of courage and
belief that human history is shaped each
time
a man stands up for an ideal or acts to
improve the light of others
or strikes out against injustice he
sends forth a tiny
ripple of hope and crossing each other
from a million different centers of
energy and daring
those ripples build a current that can
sweep down the mightiest walls of
oppression and resistance
robert kennedy might as well have been
speaking about john lewis that day
in 1964 because that's what john lewis
did and he
was more than a ripple of hope he was a
tsunami of hope
he was in every good cause there was and
he sacrificed himself
physically in south carolina in alabama
in mississippi for civil rights and he
sacrificed himself
even when he was a member of congress
for different causes getting arrested
and when he was on death's doorstep he
got himself
to washington dc to appear at black
lives matter plaza
and give hope and encouragement and
support to the young people that were
striving
for the causes that he had tried for his
whole life
i value every single moment i spent with
congressman lewis it was an honor to
know him i miss him
and just the other day i looked up at
the scoreboard
and when i didn't know quite how to vote
on some issues i would look to john
lewis and see how he voted
and he wasn't there he was my hero
thank you for giving me some time and i
yield back the balance there
you go thank you mr mr cohen we'd like
to recognize another one of mr lewis's
colleagues mr buddy carter
the gentleman from georgia mr buddy
carter is recognized
i thank the gentleman for yielding mr
speaker in our lives there are people
and places we remember
i will always remember john lewis
there are some people that you feel
especially honored to
have met you feel like you're one of the
lucky ones who had the opportunity to
hear their stories to learn their
convictions and to fill their triumphs
i believe just about anyone who had the
opportunity to meet john lewis
would agree that he is one of those
people
he was born the son of sharecroppers he
grew up on his family's farm and he
attended segregated public schools in
alabama he told his story
often and and he i remember him telling
us the story about how he used to preach
to the chickens
he went on from that humble beginning to
be called one of the most courageous
persons the civil rights movement
ever produced a title he rightfully
deserved
john lewis dedicated his entire life to
securing equality and justice for all
people while remaining a devoted
advocate for non-violence
it must have been an incredible blessing
for for him to
to see how his fight changed our nation
and the entire world
with his own eyes for me it was a
blessing to know him his office was over
in the cannon building for many years
and
my office was at the canning building
and oftentimes
as we were walking over here i i'd get
to walk with him
i hung on every moment on every word
just to have the opportunity to spend
time with
with someone like john lewis
i'll always be grateful for those walks
many of my colleagues in the georgia
delegation have mentioned the time that
he invited us to dinner at his
at his home here in washington what
great stories he told that night
truly one of the greatest experiences i
have had while i've been up here in
washington dc
john lewis was a giant among men
he will be deeply missed but his legacy
will live on forever thank you mr
speaker and i yield back gentlemen
yields back
mr walker yes sir mr speaker we would
like to recognize mr james mcgovern from
massachusetts
the gentleman from massachusetts mr
mcgovern is now recognized
mr speaker sharing a jail cell with john
lewis was one of the greatest privileges
of my life
when we were arrested for protesting the
genocide in darfur
a few years back we were put into a
police van
booked and fingerprinted john had been
arrested over 40 times
for peaceful protest by that point so
let's just say he had some advice
john made trouble like this because he
knew that words aren't enough
that real change requires action he
called it the struggle of a lifetime
but it was never his struggle alone he
challenged all of us to fight
injustice and oppression and to stand up
for civil rights
and for human rights mr speaker john was
a great man
he's an american hero who called our
country to a higher standard
but perhaps more importantly he was a
very good man
he treated every single person he met no
matter who they were
with dignity and respect and what he saw
wrong in this world he did his best
to make it right lisa patrick molly and
i miss you already john
we love you and we will never stop
making good trouble
in your name i yield back gentlemen
years back mr walker
you just like to recognize the gentleman
from ohio mr michael turner
mr turner of ohio is recognized thank
you mr speaker
john lewis has a true legacy of
leadership
in this house and he changed the world
that we live in
when congressman lewis would take the
podium everyone in this house would fall
silent
and listen to him i doubt in his long
career in this house that the speaker
ever had to hammer the house into order
to listen
to to john lewis speak
a man who fought for the voting rights
act john lewis's legacy
demands that congress act i call on
congress to pass
and send the president's desk for
signature the bipartisan h.r
1799 renewing the voting rights act
congressman lewis was a giant in history
but he was a humble man in this house
he treated every member the same
and with dignity he will be missed
are you back gentleman yells back mr
walker thank you thank you
mr speaker we'd like to recognize the
gentleman from california mr tony
cardenas
gentleman from california mr carter this
is recognized
thank you very much mr speaker
appreciate this honor
to honor one of the most beautiful human
beings
that ever walked this earth many of us
believe in god
many of us try to be the best that we
can be
but few of us are capable and able
to live a life of true love
of tremendous dignity and respect for
every single person who comes our way
i wish i could learn how to turn my
cheek the way john lewis proved
he could and did
i mourn his passing but i celebrate the
honor
of knowing that he lived and also
knowing that i could go to him on the
floor of this house or in the hallways
of congress
and go to him and speak with him and
learn from him
and then say i love you brother
and then to have him tell me and i
selfishly relish the opportunity to hear
him say
i love you too brother as i gave him a
hug
and he hugged me back i'm unfortunate
that i grew up in a very
strict household where my mother and
father only said i love you
to the big boys and girls and adults
very few times
once we got off their knee it just
didn't happen very often but john lewis
reminded me how much i missed that
and in a selfish way that's one of the
reasons why i always rushed to him and
asked him
by saying i love you to know that he
would say
i love you and with all his heart mean
it
i'm gonna miss him some of my families
were
members were
you